what is the reason for the word
comparative in the title of our program
and this is something that's unique to
our program from its founding from the
founding of CMS our faculty labs and
curriculum have all emphasized critical
analyses of the role of media in society
that are comparative in various
different ways across different media
forms spaces communities and practices
across different historical periods
across different local and global and
sub cultural contexts cultural and sub
cultural contexts utilizing
methodologies drawn from the humanities
the social sciences and computational
sciences while also drawing upon the
insights of different forms of media
production design and practice our
faculty labs and researchers reflect
this diversity in the in the approach to
critical media analysis and production
among our faculty and researchers you
will find individuals who are primarily
media practitioners others who are
primarily media scholars and theorists
and others who combine media scholarship
and practice in their work this is
particularly productive and even a quite
heady mix at times the conversations and
collaborations at Foster's are what
makes mi t--'s compared to Media Studies
program a uniquely generative space for
scholarship research and graduate study
the research groups themselves are part
of what makes your happy are part of
what makes a CMS program unique we
currently have nine research groups
under the umbrella of comparative Media
Studies each one of which is engaged at
the intersection of critical media
research practice some of these are labs
led by our faculty members with funding
from various granting agencies others
are led by research scientists and the
majority of our
master students are funded through
excuse me
through work either through work that
they do in one of the research groups or
with an individual faculty member as a
research assistant each year the program
is further enriched by visiting scholars
and practitioners visitors are often
associated with specific research groups
or and often they will also teach a
course as part of their time here so for
example one of our visitors in the open
documentary lab has gone on to teach a
course in VR production for nonfiction
storytelling our two-year curriculum
there's a mix of required foundations
courses and electives that students can
choose from within CMS has broader
offerings and I'll sort of pass things
on to Tulisa to talk a bit about the
curriculum here are the research group
directors and we also just wanted to
many supports and I'm a professor in
comparative Media Studies and I'm also
affiliated with the science technology
and society program as well and our
research groups have different directors
some our faculty and some our research
scientists and teach classes as well and
we'll probably hear more about that in a
bit beyond the research groups one of
the wonderful things about comparative
Media Studies grad program is that we
often have an array of visiting scholars
and postdocs and these are just a few of
our recent examples I don't know how
many people have heard of con easy codes
but you know a famous writer between me
and the world I believe was one of the
first books that really made him become
really famous but an incredible writer
and then we've had postdoc fellows one
of our recent postdoc fellows is Liz
Kozlov she was a Mellon post
stocke fellow here who's who came to us
from nyu as a PhD student she graduated
in the media culture and communication
department and was doing fascinating
research on media and climate change and
how communities are dealing with those
issues and then she got cherry picked by
UCLA for a very great professor job
after working here but she did she
taught a class she also worked a lot
with our other grad students and so I
bring this up because sometimes we've
got our faculty but we also have
visitors and people coming in and out of
this community that if you join the
department you would have an opportunity
to benefit from those visitors and
guests too often the opendoc lab will
have fellows who are film and media
makers and artists joining our community
and giving presentations or having
longer term residences as well so with
that overview that Vivek got us through
I also we also wanted to go through the
curriculum a little bit because you're
here not only to engage with faculty but
you will be sitting in classes right
that's part of being in graduate school
is the courses are a little different
usually you're mostly in smaller
seminars than big lecture classes
although sometimes you would have an
option to take a lecture class that's
larger but in in the first year in the
CMS graduate program during semester one
the students take three courses Media
theories and methods one so you're
introduced to theoretical works on
methodological approaches in the field
there's also a class that's required in
the core curriculum called major media
texts which focuses on approaches like
from textual analysis so you look at the
narrative structure of a film or the
meaning making processes of a game
interface how a television show develops
meanings that produce a fan community
so you're dealing with kind of the
culture and meaning making processes
embedded within the various a variety of
media film media game texts in that
class and then you do a workshop which
is more of an Applied Media Studies
class where you'll have opportunities
not just to read and think about things
but to actually make media
collaboratively with other people in
your cohort and that is often taught by
Professor Paradis he may pop in later
but the students tend to really like
that class as a way of breaking up a lot
of the reading that you end up doing in
the other classes in the workshop class
you're getting your hands on equipment
you're learning data visualization
skills you might do a media mapping
project to deal with a particular
phenomenon you might even just do a
short video project that documents
something of interest to you and your
group beyond that then we have a
colloquium and we actually have one
today at five o'clock for those of you
that can stick around in the head of our
department Eric will be giving a talk
but colloquium is every week up from
5:00 to 6:30 or 7:00 and that tends to
be a time of listening to people come
give lectures about their work usually
we have people both on campus and off
campus come and give colloquium talks
and you get usually have a yummy meal of
pizza or whatever you've been having
lately a lot of pizza salad for those of
you that like healthy food and there's a
lot of it's kind of like a community
bringing the group of the grad students
together with faculty and other
researchers in the community we usually
hold that over in the media lab building
in this comparative Media Studies area
and just to give you a sense of some of
the recent talks we've had we Professor
William a Riccio who some of you may
know he's a media historian and also his
director of co-director involved in
leading the opendoc lab he gave a talk
recently Lucy Suchman who is a really
interesting
scholar in science technology and
society and some of her work is also
overlapping with human-computer
interaction which is the field of
research
she came last week and gave a really
fascinating talk and standing-room-only
we were kind of you know students and
myself included we're sitting on the
floor for a while and because there were
so many people there and then another
talk about Imperial arrangements South
African apartheid and the force of
photography by Kimberly Juanita brown so
just to give you a since we you can go
on our website and look at an archive of
podcasts that exists for a sense of
talks we get in the second year during
semester one you do a class called media
and transition which is a historical
class that zooms in on moments in which
media technologies are in flux and are
shifting and a lot of times that's at a
moment where media formats also get
reconfigured redefined and chewed off in
new directions so so that classes class
has been taught by William a Riccio as
well as EDI Appa I believe in others
then you take two electives that's an
exciting semester because you're not
required to just I mean our core is
wonderful and robust and rigorous and
creative but here's a semester where you
get to take two electives outside of the
core curriculum of CMS and you can use
that opportunity to take classes in an
area that may dovetail with the thesis
that you're going to be developing later
that in in that second year so and then
you also continue to participate in the
colloquium during the semester two of
you a semester second semester of year
two you're you're pretty much focusing
exclusively on your thesis research and
you're writing it up we have an exciting
thesis day in April and all of the
students present their theses in public
and do a presentation that's live
streamed
attended by members of the MIT community
as well as the Greater Boston area we
have sometimes people coming from around
the area for that event and beyond that
did you just I'll just add in terms of
the thesis one of the you know since it
is a relatively short you know two-year
program the the process of developing
the thesis is baked into the core
courses so for example from the very
first semester one of the assignments
one of the end of your assignments of
one of the core classes has you create a
document a annotated bibliography around
a particular topic that you are sort of
leaning towards in in terms of an area
that you may want to explore for your
thesis so you start you know reading
some of the the texts that might be the
most relevant for that that topic and
and then in the second and third
semesters each semester ends with sort
of another step closer to your thesis I
believe that the second semester of the
first year at the end of that semester
you produce a thesis proposal and then
over the the summer in between the two
years often students will be using that
period of time to start doing research
on their thesis topic that then they'll
be working into the actual writing
process in the second year so it's the
that part of the the process that thesis
writing processes is built into the
curriculum in that way you know we have
people in their first year right now
which are know we're getting to the
toward the end of the first semester of
the first year for our current cohort
and they're turning in an annotated
bibliography in the media theories and
methods class and that bibliography is
supposed to support a thesis related
topic so you look into
bunch of different research articles and
books related to an area that you are
personally interested in to do that
background research on a kind of
literature review to prepare you to
conduct further research in an area so
as Vivek was saying that it's it's set
up to allow a facilitation process of
your research evolving incrementally and
then culminating in the end of the
second year into the thesis and that's
always a really exciting process for us
just to see what people come up with to
give you a sense of recent examples my I
really have to have my glasses changed
look I'm here kiss the screen on here is
really small this was a couple of years
ago but we had a variety of different
topics I'm not going to read them all
but they arranged from you know local
journalism and and civic life to you
know study at social media and disease
outbreaks and how social media are were
kind of integral in reporting on disease
outbreaks the theses that if you do we
have a full like a list of all of them
online I encourage you if you're
thinking about applying to the program
and getting a sense of the kind of work
that gets done to look at a full list
online because it really gives you a
sense of all the possibilities here it's
not a program that really tries to
funnel you in a really narrow direction
instead it's a program that's a platform
where you can really flourish in terms
of exploring your own interests and
dialogue with the faculty and also your
peers
I think the cohorts get a lot of
solidarity and learn a lot from one
another to these species don't just sit
in a dusty old library somewhere
sometimes they end up turning into books
and we're really proud that many of our
alums
taken their theses and turned them into
books and I'm just going to flip through
a few of these Molly
Salter's the coming swarm we have a
swine's book from Bombay to Bollywood I
have I've read some of these but not all
so I need to add some of these to my
reading list this is nice
Candice callouses book how climate
change comes to matter
I believe she gave a commencement
address here at MIT last year didn't she
yes so this is an alum out of CMS who
was giving a commencement address to the
doctoral ceremony here last year and she
was just invited to the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences as well so some of
our alums go on to not only publish
books but also to do really high-impact
work here's another one called
networking peripheries technological
futures and the myth of digital
universalism the list keeps going on a
lot of times master species don't turn
into books so you should know that
usually it's a PhD dissertation that
comment becomes a book not off on a
master's thesis so we also have Kevin
Driscoll's book on mini tell Brian
Jacobson's books studio before the
assistant studios before the system
unlike the electrification of the
electrification infrastructure in the
Paris film studios at the turn of the
century this is a long list that what is
this one called accounts a gas gas
stutter
I don't know this project do you but
we're showing all these slides because
we are just really proud of these people
and then alumni do a variety of
different careers they some of them go
into academia and or published books and
become kind of public intellectuals and
contribute through their writing and
scholar
ship and others go into the media
industries we've had people be radio and
podcast strategist a fellow in the San
Francisco mayor's office of civic
innovation somebody went on to be a
manager of digital entertainment at the
Andy Warhol Museum product manager Apple
consumer intelligence a program manager
at Etsy of grad student that just
graduated last year Matt great and from
CMS just got a job last week a pretty
high-level job in the area of trust and
digital safety and security at Twitter
another student from a couple years ago
just went to I do so so interesting
career placement happens out of the
program and we're really proud of the
alums especially the having 20 years of
alums and a community that stays pretty
well networked thanks to Andrew
Whittaker who always updates our alumni
online so we encourage you to have a
look I'm sure some of you have already
looked at the website but we encourage
you to go check out a lot more
information that's available on that
website and if you have questions make
sure to reach out to us to individual
faculty members to our staff in the
department Shannon is a total expert
when it comes to the graduate program
and it really couldn't be run without
her we also have with us today professor
Jing Wang who is a faculty member in CMS
and maybe we could have you talk a
little bit about the work that you do
yeah sure nice meeting you all
my name is Jane Wayne and I've been
teaching at MIT since 2001 so it's been
18 years my research revolves around
Media and its impact on civic
communities on one hand and its impact
on entertainment industry on the other
hand I just finished writing a book on
civic media which was based on my 10
year long experience of running a
grassroots NGO in Shenzhen China my
collaborators in China and I practice
ICT powered activism you know what ICT
stands for information communication
technology so I have a second life
outside of Cambridge Massachusetts at
the same time I'm also pursuing research
on the digital disruptions in the media
sector and I look at the the current
trends just to give you some ideas time
shifted viewing narrowcasting TV
everywhere social ecommerce and
interactive video so those are trends
that have brought the industry both in
the US and in China and I look at both
the technology and business aspects of
those disruptions asking who benefited
who benefited from them and what the
ecosystem of streaming media looks like
and how the future of content likely
would likely evolve so that's a really
quick bird's-eye view of what I do now
to give you a general sense of the
diverse research interests of our former
graduate students Lisa
professor Lisa parks showed us some
thesis some thesis titles I'm going to
share with you more titles of a few
theses that I supervised so here's the
list a case study of the ARS electronica
future lab experiments in corporate
collaboration ARS electronica is an
Austrian cultural educational and
like Institute they were active in the
new field of media arts and then the
other one is negotiating realist the
sixth generation of Chinese filmmakers
electric science in Manhattan 1881 to
1917 that was a thesis on outdoor
advertising journey to the east the
remake of Chinese animation aligned BBS
sphere sphere PBS is a traditional
internet forum system the hidden
activism media practices and media
opportunities in the Chinese politics of
resistance and hackers geeks and makers
creativity in the Chinese technology
community and the last one theorizing a
decentralized Internet controversies
over data ownership recommendation
system and surveillance capitalism so
this is just a wise you can tell there
are the diverse topics of research
interests and I look forward to learning
from you about your English thank you
yes I'll talk a little bit about the MIT
game lab around the research coordinator
I'm Michael Jacobson by the way and we
do teaching with the research and we
also play games we have about six or
seven classes that we offer roughly half
of them on game design in one form or
another and the others about game
culture and understanding games as a
cultural media phenomenon
and we often there's two of the class
the classes I teach have graduate
student versions of them so one is
introduction to video game theory and
the other one is playful and social
interaction design exploration so it's a
the second one it's the studio based
class for graduate students where we do
design research and trying to figure out
what that means in terms of what kind of
findings you can hope for on how to
disseminate them or evaluate them as
well a couple of the projects that we're
doing in the lab currently we're doing
one that sort of has exploded into a
number of sub projects so we've started
out this study of colonialist themes in
board games just playing and critiquing
these games which is a book project that
I have together with Professor miracle
and again from Dartmouth College but in
the process we got so fed up with these
colonialist themes so we started doing
post-colonial or counter colonial games
together with game designers from
communities that have been negatively
affected by colonialism so we've been
going to Puerto Rico and working doing
workshops with game designers there that
has sprouted a board game which is in
produce prototype stage right now so
we're we're going to have a visiting
artist from Puerto Rico a comic book
artist coming next semester to work with
us on illustrations in graphic design
and for the design of
of that game that we will in some form
publish later next year we've also been
going to Columbia and we've been doing
workshops here at MIT
with game designers who are interested
in these issues and want to see poor
games but also video games dealing with
these issues in more interesting
fruitful ways another project that we're
currently doing is sponsored by post the
headphone manufacturers so they have
developed new technology for audio
augmented reality so often when we say
always think of the things that digital
things that appear to exist out in our
physical environment but in this case it
would be auditory objects or auditory
sware spheres that are being placed in
our environment and we can experience
them with our ears as we move through
them and so for us this was an
opportunity again to to have students
practice design based research and and
try to populate so far very sparsely
populated design space of audio AR
artifacts and see if we can sort of
tease out what potential qualities and
use experiences that that can exist in
that space so that project is started
out over summer with us and some
undergrad researchers working with us in
the lab as coming up with seeds of the
of mechanics that that can could then be
used by the students in the class that
we're currently teaching during the fall
semester and then we're going to switch
back into research and production mode
again in January and hire some of the
students from the class to work with us
in the project to to refine some of the
the more interesting ideas to to high
fidelity prototypes we do a lot of
development we are a functioning game
development studio on campus but we
usually don't go all the way to a
commercial product because a lot of the
interest we have in the games that we're
making is understanding things that can
only be understood by actually creating
the thing but often we we get the
understanding or the knowledge that we
need before is being taken all the way
to a fully polished marketable
commercial product so it happens
sometimes in terms of students painting
off their ideas for themselves or in the
in the case of the the new Puerto Rico
board game where we have been talking to
board game publishers who just liked the
idea so that much that they want to work
with us to to make it a accessible
product even if they can't make any
money from it so finally the the playing
games part we believe that if we are
going to be experts at this thing it's
not enough that we study games and that
we make games and we teach games we also
have to continue playing games to not
sort of lose touch with with the essence
of the thing that
pretending to be experts at so so we
tried to play games at least once a week
depending on the cohorts the graduate
students are more or less engaged in
those activities but but when it comes
to the colonial board games I really
need people to help me play these games
that can sometimes be quite depressing
and racist and so on but we also try to
balance that with also playing games for
fun since we're doing the bose project
right now we've been doing a lot of
breathing rhythm games and other music
games we've sort of gone through the
history of railing games from from early
japanese first generation playstation
games to current state of the genre and
there's strong ties there to MIT to
Harmonix being founded by I think that's
it okay so as I said I'm Vivek bald and
I am a documentary filmmaker and
historian and I also work in sort of
newer forms of digital media based
storytelling my my kind of broad
interests in in the field of media have
to do with the intersection between
media or the connection between media
and both the exercise and and
contestation of power so my my
theoretical background within within
Media Studies is really on the cultural
studies side particularly British
cultural studies and
you know work that that has sort of
looked at both the ways that that states
and corporations sort of consolidate and
maintain power social power as well as
the ways in which everyday people or
subcultures then are able to challenge
that power challenge representations
with counter representations etc in the
field of popular culture that that has
been sort of a grounding for me both as
a documentary filmmaker and as a scholar
some of my scholarship is more
traditionally historical I my interests
on that side have to do with histories
of immigration to the United States and
very particularly Asian and South Asian
immigration during the period from the
late 19th century to the mid 20th
century when when migration from Asia
had been banned in way that's sort of
similar to what had been has been called
for by the current administration with
regard to Muslim immigration so there
was an entire you know period of almost
60 70 years when when migration from
Asia was banned and that's the
historical period that I look at in
particular looking at a couple of early
communities of undocumented Muslim
migrants from what is now present-day
Bangladesh and West Bengal in India and
these were men who worked on colonial
steamships and then jumped ship in US
ports and sort of disappeared into other
communities of color and married within
those communities so that particular
project is not just a historical you
know work of historical scholarship it's
a book but I'm working working on this
as a transmedia project where the book
is just one out of
parts of the larger project the second
and third at which being I'm currently
finishing feature-length documentary
film that is slated for broadcast on PBS
that follows the son of one of these men
who jump ship in New York in the 1930s
and settled in Harlem and then the third
part of it is a web-based or a history
project which is a kind of platform for
the descendants of this kind of unique
community to record their own stories
upload photographs and essentially be
engaged in the telling of their own
history
so that that particular project with
that particular project I'm on the long
term interested in how we can use
different forms of media particularly
digital media to create spaces for those
who have been written out of history to
author their own history you know and in
means that are that have not typically
been have not typically counted as
historical archives in other words
through oral traditions of storytelling
as well as things like family
photographs so I'm creating a digital
platform for for that to occur I teach
courses in documentary film production
one is centered on the production of
short documentaries for the web like
three to five-minute documentaries it's
a you know a form that has has really
flourished in the last ten years or so
and and kind of touches you know goes in
many different directions there's
another course that I teach regularly on
social justice and documentary film
where we watch and kind of analyze and
critique recent social documentaries as
well as working teams typically three to
four teams will work toward creating
their own roughly ten minute
at the end of the semester and I I also
I'm also a member of the open
documentary lab I'm one of the the
faculty affiliates of the lab which has
mentioned with is run by my colleague
William Muir Keough and my other
colleagues Sarah wall isn't the open
documentary lab was started about six
years ago maybe really as space to
gather people who are either working in
or writing about thinking about new
forms of documentary storytelling that
have been made possible by new forms of
technologies whether it's streaming and
the possibility of creating
documentaries that are nonlinear than
interactive where the user is able to
kind of move around the kind of digital
space to look at different parts of a
documentary to like game interfaces
again as a way of navigating through
different parts of the story to virtual
reality based documentaries and
augmented reality documentary so these
are all things that that the open
documentary lab is is has been engaged
with both in terms of bringing in
fellows who meet once a week and are
often you know here in the area over the
course of either a semester or a year
and they're typically people who are
already working in different fields
whether it's journalism photojournalism
documentary filmmaking or technologists
other forms of storytellers so so that's
a really fertile space and we're also I
think typically one student per semester
over the last one student per cohort
sorry over the last few years has been
an RA in that lab and takes part in both
ODS research as well as the kind of
interchange that happens
with the fellows so yeah that's me
and he gave a great colloquium talk this
semester where we got a preview of his
film in progress - which was really
wonderful
so I guess before we open it up for
questions I'll say a little bit about
myself as a professor here and and the
research that I do so I am a humanities
based media scholar and my research has
tended to focus in three general areas
although I don't sometimes it meanders
beyond that but I've done research on
satellite technologies and media
globalization on surveillance culture
and on an area called media
infrastructure studies where we kind of
look not just at the screen content or
the audience but we think about the
distribution systems in the world that
allow content to circulate whether we're
talking about satellites or the internet
or local Wi-Fi systems there are a whole
host of infrastructures that are
necessary for audio-visual content to be
able to move from a distribution point
to audiences worldwide and so I've been
trying to find different
interdisciplinary methods for studying
those infrastructures and because of
that sometimes my research as a media
scholar also overlaps into fields like
with international relations
sometimes with cultural geography and
sometimes with art and I've collaborated
with people across those fields as well
and I really like those kind of
interdisciplinary collaborations in
addition to doing research I direct the
global media technologies and cultures
lab here at MIT and I should
that I just moved here what is it almost
three or four years ago from University
of California Santa Barbara where I
taught in the film and Media Studies
department there for about 18 years
before moving across the country and
coming over here and so so I when I was
there I directed a research center
called the Center for information
technology in society and I learned a
lot through that process that I tried to
also bring into the lab that I created
here and I'll just give you a snippet of
ways that we're working in the lab right
now we have a grant from the National
Science Foundation with a colleague from
UCLA now named Ramin Srinivasan he just
published an interesting book called
Beyond the Valley about computing and
information technologies beyond Silicon
Valley in rural more rural
disenfranchised communities around the
world but we're working together to try
to understand how people in rural
communities that are beyond political
capitals and cultural capitals how do
they think about and use the Internet in
their everyday lives and do they think
about the infrastructure that they use
to connect to the internet and what do
they know about it are they curious
about it are they interested in it are
they do they feel empowered by it
do they feel a sense of ownership over
it so our project is called network
sovereignty because we're interested in
how people that don't see themselves at
the center of political processes are
imagining the Internet in their everyday
life worlds so we've been doing
fieldwork in Tanzania and my part of the
project has been in Tanzania in Africa
and and Ramesh has been working in
Mexico and then part of the project also
links with the Blackfeet nation the
Blackfeet Indian tribe in the United
States and territories in Mont
and so with that project I've had an
opportunity to have the students in CMS
that have been working with me
but go to Tanzania with me and actually
help with the fieldwork and we did a
separate workshop when we were there I
had another student come to Montana with
me last summer and run a forum in
browning Montana to try to get a sense
of how people that live in the Blackfeet
nation think about the internet and
social media and how and whether they
feel any empowerment and ownership over
the systems that kind of end in their
sovereign lands or whether they feel
that the ownership is elsewhere so like
we they I'm also interested in a lot of
the power relationships that are woven
into the media and information
technologies that we use in the world so
that network sovereignty project we have
a blog on I should pull up my we have a
lab website that you're feel feel free
to check it out we have a blog that we
just started populating in the last
couple of months with a bunch of posts
related to the overall topic of network
sovereignty so we do outreach to
different scholars and activists that
are also wanting to write up their work
and share it as part of a research
community we also have another part of
our website blog and often these blog
posts are written by grad students who
are working in the lab and I'm not going
to go into all of these but they're
doing a wonderful job the most recent
one that I'm just copy editing is by
Diego who is from Peru and just did an
interview about all the gig economy work
in / in Peru and how all the protests
are going they're going on in relation
to some of the work there and we're
working on projects related to
surveillance and a whole bunch of other
issues too we don't have time to go into
everything but I'm happy to answer
questions of people
them so with that I think we should open
it up to people's questions oh you want
to have one I'm gay the Internet
okay potential applicant from Iran who
says I'm currently finishing my doctoral
studies in theater and performance
studies my main focus is critical race
Theory middle-eastern and migration
studies
I'm mr. stood in CMS to explore digital
racial formation on Iranian social
networks and video games particularly in
relation to u.s. cultural colonialism
and surveillance culture given this I
was wondering if my background and
overall research interests could fit the
purview of your program and the training
you offer well I would I would say I
mean yes the the the way in which you've
described the this project very liked it
immediately for me resonates in a number
of different levels as as someone who
studies issues of Empire and global
inequities and in power particularly
with relation to South Asia and the
British Empire in South Asia as well as
the ways in which different forms of
orientalist representations of South
Asians in the United States have sort of
played into both the ways in which South
Asians have been simultaneously
celebrated and demonized in in the US
and so my more recent work is is sort of
centered on on drawing out a kind of
genealogy of those processes going back
to the late 19th century up until the
present and you know migration and
immigration both and and political exile
and and sojourning all these various
different forms of global movement of
people's as really at the center of all
the work that
I've done so you know that sounds like
an exciting project and and I'm sure
they're there also overlaps Lisa with
your work yeah there's so many different
ways to conduct research on surveillance
practices and we really need to
understand from more international
perspectives how those technologies and
practices are taking shape in different
parts of the world and what different
policies countries have around those
technologies I'm actually working on a
project right now based on some research
we we did last December in Washington DC
I took a graduate student working in my
lab we went to Washington DC and and did
interviews with a lot of the the
satellite operators and we were mostly
looking at the distribution of the
Internet but we had another project in
DC where we were also interviewing those
who are working in digital rights
advocacy organizations like Electronic
Frontier Foundation ACLU epic the Center
for Democracy and Technology and
interviewing the people that are the
workers on the frontlines of digital
privacy and in how our what sources are
they using to research surveillance
activities and how are they setting
their advocacy agendas because what we
see is a lot of big tech companies using
black boxing they they protect access to
they kind of control access to
information about the technology and
their internal operations so it's really
hard to know how these technologies are
operating and we need to be really
creative and inventive about how we do
research on surveillance system
given the proprietary claims that big
tech make to their algorithms and their
their practices so I'm writing that up
right now with the colleague we call it
surveillance pressure points and we're
looking at all this proliferating
surveillance pressure points in the
world
oh yes and and I'm a I'm a lean on your
institutional memory and in terms of the
first question is about the the process
of going from master's thesis to book
and whether the whether there's
institutional support for for that for
that process or whether it happened
independently is that correct
and so I'll just I'll I'll start to
answer that question myself and that is
my understanding
and Shannon me may correct me if I'm
wrong my understanding is that often
that process the the thesis de book
project process is something that
happens after people have been in the
program
sometimes when masters masters theses
are then further developed into PhD
theses dissertations and then turned
into books that said you know everyone
on faculty have been through the process
of of turning a thesis whether it's you
know typically again a PhD thesis but
turning going through the process of
turning that kind of research that is
initially presented within academia into
books that are aimed at aimed at often
broader audiences outside of academia
and so you know we're able to advise on
on that process based on our own
experiences our knowledge of different
publishers etc so that's you know that's
part of what we do for those students
who are interested in going in that
route and also for those students
there's some amount of students every
year who decide that they want to go on
to a ph.d program and so we've typically
also been in that role of supporting
students who are trying to choose
between different programs and
and then often writing letters of
recommendation etcetera for those who
want to take that route and the second
part of the question sorry I focused on
the first one the second question the
second part of the question was to what
extent does CMS overlap with the Haas
program some of the the graduates from
CMS have actually applied once they
finish their masters they apply into
that program so there are some students
who have taken that route and in fact I
think there's one student Mariela is in
there right now and you know I think
there are some faculty that are even
affiliated with that program so you
could also take elective classes from
faculty members who are teaching in that
program if it worked with your schedule
on so there is a relationship it's I
don't know how formalized it is but
there's certainly like you know movement
across CMS and hats in terms of students
and faculty and the the colloquium that
we had last week with Lucy Suchman was a
Haas related event to STS helped to
co-organized that with our department
and so a lot of the students from that
program that our doctoral students were
were there so you would have
opportunities for over overlap I think
and conversely their students sometimes
seek out CMS professors to work with on
their dissertation
I have another question from the
interwebs I'm gonna summarize this a
little bit because it's a fairly long
question but there is a woman who has
been reading about the logistics economy
in the us-mexico border and about
silicon border a 9,000 acre development
on the Mexico side of the border and is
wondering if CMS is a program where she
could conduct research on surveillance
and tech investment in the border region
for a scholarly thesis but also with a
speculative novella component allegorize
in the technological landscape in the
border region as part of the thesis
that's a question I have not come across
before you so I'll toss that out to you
guys talk about the person yeah I mean
well there's certainly a kind of
emergent move in the discipline of Media
Studies to focus on this sub area called
logistical media or sometimes it's
called located media but to really study
how media are involved in mapping and
tracking the movement of people and
objects in the world even you know not
just entertainment but even how its
involved in the global supply chain in a
way so there's a lot of interest in
logistical media and surveillance within
comparative Media Studies in terms of
the format of the thesis I think there
have been options to do a more
conventional scholarly part of the
thesis combined with a creative
dimension of it and I think there's a
pretty clear precedent for that and that
you would just need to be in close
dialogue with the the person you select
to be the mentor of your thesis or the
adviser for your thesis and committee
members to keep them informed about your
thoughts and to to be open to advice
about how you might shape it - yeah I
mean that has been it's been common
within the program - to incorporate one
or
another form of creative productive you
know practice based work as parts of
feces there have been pcs in the past
that were done in where there was a
written component as well as a short
documentary and/or interactive project
of some kind there last year one of our
students Rika Mehrotra did a podcast
series as part of her written thesis or
in combination with the written thesis
there are some written theses that that
take the productive the production
element that they do as sort of as a
case study about which to write the
thesis as well right I'm Shannon there
have been cases where the the production
part is not sort of an additional
component but actually part of the
process of doing the research and and
you know when it comes to speculative
fiction I mean I think that our the CMS
program is would be a unique place in in
regard to the fact that we are as a
larger unit connected to writing
compared to media studies and writing is
our larger unit and we have a number of
very of really amazing people to work
with on the writing side and there have
been faculty members who are
predominantly you know teach on the
writing in teach writing who have acted
as thesis advisors and and readers etc
so you know I think that there would be
an opportunity to do to do that kind of
award I have something to add
is not directly related to the questions
but I noticed that we have international
students sometimes there are needs for
international students to do field work
as part of them the process of working
on your thesis and we have we have a
program on campus which is called misty
that sends graduate students during the
IEP the month of January and the
summertime they provide fellowships for
graduate students to go to let's say
Brazil or China to do intern to do
internships which enables the students
to collect data and to incorporate field
work into their theses yeah an example
of that is a student last year a Chilean
student wanted to study how indigenous
Mapuche communities in Chile who live in
areas where there are a lot of natural
resource extraction how they were how
their lives were being affected by state
police drones that were flying around so
she actually got one of those grants to
go and do field work in those areas and
engage with the community so that she
could understand from their perspective
she did some photographic and video
documentation as well and then that
became part of her written thesis so her
thesis was a write-up of her findings
but it was heavily documented with video
materials and also maps that she created
but she benefited from one of those
grants so if you'd like to do a kind of
more field based ethnical
ethnographically inspired type of
research I think our program is very
open to that that kind of work and you
know
thanks for mentioning that I've got
another one we have a very active
chapter this this may apply for me to
some people in the audience as well
which is what recommendations do you
have for prospective applicants who are
currently professionals and haven't been
students for some time more than five
years that's a really good question
that's it's important because we
actually like to be a program that we're
open to people that have been out in the
workforce for a while after graduating
from school and had maybe a few years of
work and want to come back to do a
masters some of our students also just
continue on straight from doing their
bachelor's degree into a masters but if
you've been out in the workforce for a
while from my own opinion and maybe the
other panelists have different feelings
I think the writing sample is really
important I think one of the things we
value when we're looking at the
applications and files is to see that
you can actually write clearly and
thoughtfully and so taking time to
really work on the writing sample and
make sure it's as polished a piece of
writing as you can before submitting it
would be an important thing to do and
then sometimes when you've been out of
in the workforce for a while you're not
as connected to people academic people
who might write letters of
recommendation it's important that
people who do write letters of
recommendation can really speak in
detail about your strengths as a student
and as somebody who can contribute to
the community and be able to comment on
things you have done in the past that
are suggestive of your success in a
graduate program and I'll just add as
someone who I was working in documentary
film production and web production for
about 12 years before I decided to
pursue a graduate degree
one thing that so a couple of things one
is that you know there's a we recognize
a great value in that in bringing that
experience into the program and you know
because often and I know this was the
case with my own in my own experience is
that I hadn't had him quite a clear idea
by the time I went to graduate school of
why I wanted to be there and how it sort
of fit in in an overall trajectory that
was going from documentary film into
academia and what I would say and this
is this is a case really for everybody
but perhaps even more so for those
who've been out of academia for for a
period of time it's important in your in
your narrative that you that you sent
the narrative part of your application
to us to convey to us a kind of your own
trajectory you know why is it you know
what have you been doing in the past X
number of years how has it led you to
the point where you want to go to
graduate school why this graduates
program and what you hope to do here
that is in a sense you know building on
whatever has brought you to this point
in time right so it's really helpful for
us to to see you spell out that
trajectory and how this program how you
imagined this program would fit in that
trajectory so if you've been you know
working in media or in any field for the
last five six years you know what is it
that you know that either that work has
brought you to that you want to explore
in greater detail or what what has it
been that has been lacking in that work
that you feel really drawn to and you
feel like this is the place where you
could actually delve into you know these
other interests or ideas
and and then how you see all of that
sort of adding up to what you might do
afterwards so and you know a lot of us
work in forms of narrative forms of
media so so creating your own narrative
and kind of giving us a sense of your
own narrative and how the program fits
is always a really good way to think
about your approach to your essay
section of the or the you know narrative
state of the statement part of your
application well we can't have all the
questions from the web
that's a tough question I mean every
year is different obviously but
oh yes the question is the question is
what we're looking for in a cohort and
you know I would say it's different
every year because it's a different
group of people who are applying every
year but I think that because because
there's a great variety in what our
Faculty's interests are that typically
then translates to to a similar variety
in in the students that are admitted
each year because they're clearly there
are certain there are certain students
who you know would appear to have a
particular kind of synergy with a
particular faculty member or you know
explicitly you know want to we work with
a particular faculty member you know
there are people who are drawn because
we have some faculty who work in gaming
some faculty who work in in you know
whether it's satellite technologies etc
so it's you know that variety in what we
do typically creates a great variety in
who applies and then translates into a
variety of within each cohort so and
yeah I mean I don't know whether that
that kind of answers your question I
mean there's sort of I guess what I'm
trying to say is that that there's a
that variety of sort of built in in in
some way so every every Court is going
to have people were interested in
different things and people who are
coming from different backgrounds in
terms of what we were talking about
before some people who are coming
straight out of college or recently out
of college other who's been working
others who have been working in
different fields for a while and that's
that's what keeps each I think each
cohort really dynamic is that that range
say we try to strike a balance of
intellectual diversity also diversity in
terms of place so in in the last few
years I think we we try harder to make
sure we have international students we
also have minority students right yeah
so it's it also depends upon the poll
but we do think about gender and racial
and ethnic diversity we also I think we
even think about class issues I remember
somebody applied and wrote a really
compelling personal statement about
growing up in a working-class white
rural community and yet working really
hard in school and really wanting to be
at MIT and I believe that person is now
a student at UC Berkeley law school you
know I haven't come out of our program
so it could be you know and we we have
admitted a lot of international students
for me that's a priority I in in trying
to think about my lab to wanting to have
international perspectives in our
classrooms and so that we learn from
diverse viewpoints from around the world
and one way that we can that that can
happen is by admitting international
students as well and students from the
North America that have a lot to offer
so yeah it's it's a good question
there's not like a formula that we have
but we do think about diversity
carefully a lot of us that serve on the
community committees yeah there was
another hand back there
there is there is place within the
within the application to to submit a
portfolio of work is that
Shannon is that is that that's an
optional portfolio is optional
many of our applicants do submit
additional material yeah so the question
was do we recommend that people submit
additional materials just very right and
so what we tend to get most of is a
writing sample because a lot of the
people that serve on the admissions
committee like to see that the person
can not just write a personal statement
but maybe can submit a sample of a
research paper that they've done because
some of the some of you would be coming
in and being assigned to a research lab
and so those lab directors want to see
that you could work on a collaborative
team and contribute your research skills
to help out let's say you how to go look
up a whole bunch of citations and help
with the publication of an article or so
having a writing sample that shows that
you you can do research and that shows
critical and analytical skills of some
kind yeah yeah and sometimes people
submit like an audio-visual portfolio if
they've worked on films or game projects
they submit that as an as an attachment
to so yeah we're links to a website with
the online portfolio sometimes
the question was can it be a collab if
you're submitting materials on the
portfolio can it be a collaboration with
a professor or others or does it have to
be single authored I would say comedic a
collaboration it's fine as long as it's
identified as such and if you're a
co-author or a co-creator of something
just to make sure that all the
authorship is indicated so that that's
accurate and other people's efforts are
represented and you know if it's if it's
work that that you feel we should be
thinking about as a significant part of
your application then you know it may be
that you want to work into your
statement you know writing about what
role what specific roles you played in
that that particular project and you
know what you might have gained from it
or what what in that project sparked
your interest in you know what you're
interested in now etc so so you know in
other words those elements that the
portfolio
could be not just sort of finished works
but also opportunities for you to talk
about your experience and interests
yes no cohort is perfect as I was
wondering when the students have
problems where do they have problems
Shannon you might want to Shannon's the
first line and often miss Joan is that
word always tough one so we've had we
had a couple of students who felt that
there was a problem with MIT and race
last year
and but that's that was fairly new to us
most students have they come in and they
have problems it is with the the load of
the academic work balancing with the
research assistant work and trying to
balance the time management sometimes we
have problems that are utterly
completely unrelated like when poro
Safinaz apartment building burned down
and fYI there's a team at MIT called the
care team that is called to action when
these things happen and they have
representatives from all across the
Institute that can help find emergency
housing emergency food funding and
things like that I it's hard to say if
there's any typical problems that arise
every year we we try if students are
having a tough time in any particular
area and it seems to be all the students
are having a tough time we try to
address that area so that it doesn't get
to be a problem in the future is that I
think as a matter of practice it's also
just I think the faculty try to
encourage the students to come directly
to them if they have an issue maybe you
know if there was an issue in a class
being taught or the readings were the
the volume of the reading were too heavy
and you know I think some people will
really encourage the students to provide
direct feedback and have that kind of
rapport so I think that's an informal
way that some challenges might get
addressed and I we have a director of
Graduate Studies that the students could
go to and report problems or complaints
or issues and usually once that would
happen Shannon would be looped in as
well and sometimes even the department
head there's also the Dean of graduate
education here at MIT her name is
Blanche Dayton and she is gets quite
involved if there are student issues
that emerge that need to be addressed
and there are associate Dean's in her
office that also meet regularly with
students I have noticed a shift just in
my own experience in terms of the
students here as opposed to the
University of California system I think
this is a really intense work
environment for students and sometimes
people can get overwhelmed and so I do
think it's really important if you were
to come here and to just make sure to
reach out to people and let folks know
if you need support or help and I feel
that this campus does want to do
whatever it can to try to offer
assistance and resources even more so
than other some other campuses but it is
you know it's a it's a very high level
Research Institute and it can be
pressure cooker for some so I think you
know it's it's important just to be
aware of that and it thinks the cohorts
have their solidarities sometimes - that
are really helpful
yeah the small cohort does
at the undergraduate level the the
built-in safety nets are much more
implicit there's a lot more intervention
that will happen if a student seems to
becoming overwhelmed at the graduate
level there is there are tremendous
resources available but the it's assumes
that a graduate student will know
themselves well enough to ask for help
people won't necessarily intervene
unless it seems to be the situation is
very very dire but the resources are
there for students who need them
I missed the very first part of it it is
how focused does our students research
interests usually when they come in and
once they're exposed to the broader
intellectual community of MIT do they
change it's it's a really important
question because with a master's program
that's two years long with the idea of
completing a thesis at the end of the
second year it goes by very quickly and
so I think it's this balancing act of
wanted coming in with some some general
idea of what you want to focus on but
also allowing yourself to be open to the
courses you're taking the readings that
you're doing and and what you're
learning and being able to refine that
general idea or concentrated or directed
in a way that's gonna you know position
you to be able to be benefiting from and
receptive to what you're learning but
since it goes very quickly what I've
witnessed is that the students that tend
to be able to finish their theses and
feel pretty good about them come in with
a pretty pretty good idea of what they
want to focus on and then they're able
to use their assignments and their
seminar classes to do work that's geared
toward completing the thesis even though
not all of the coursework might be
directly related to the thesis so it's a
little bit of a balancing act if I'm
wanting to have something in mind but we
have seen people change course and say I
came in thinking I wanted to do this but
now that I've taken the first semester
of classes I really know that I don't
want to do that and I want to do this so
I think you should feel free to be open
to that possibility that's not uncommon
yeah I I'm afraid I have to duck out to
go teach but thanks
we'll let you guys continue thank you
thanks so much if there are no questions
I have questions for you I'm just
curious about what you're looking for
you know Media Studies program what
brought you here do you have some ideas
what kind of yeah I think you'll
definitely find that people embrace the
study of technology and many and the
humanities and social sciences and even
the arts here would think about it as
the foundational assumption might be
that it's that technology is always
about socio-technical relations as
opposed to a kind of tech techne that's
separate from the social or the human
and I think a lot of people in different
ways are investigating that set of
relationships so
earlier cultural training especially
with all the writing
the critique is actually pretty good not
be
the short answer to that is sort of
there are there is cultural competency
training available to faculty but it is
difficult to require faculty to to do
that kind of training most of our
faculty are very interested in cultural
competency in this study of implicit
bias in addition to the study of their
own research and so I think they are
interested in critique as opposed to
bias but I can't say that everyone has
been required to do that yeah I I don't
think there's there's not formal
cultural competency training sessions
here at MIT I think that some of the
faculty have tried to read in certain
literature's to try to understand the
complexity of race relations and
ethnicities in relation as well as
complex issues related to gender and
sexuality but it's not it's not
mandatory in terms of our faculty
training I think there are some that are
more interested in and open to those
discussions intellectually and as a
matter of education and practice and
some you know tend to not prioritize
that as much in their work but overall
our I think our faculty are really open
to talking through and trying to address
the issues that I think are underlying
your your question it's an important
thing to raise
I have a few more comments on yeah sure
as you asked what people were but what
drew them oh yeah
so now Kali Iran says I became
interested in this program because a
friend in the MIT Media Lab suggested I
look into the interdisciplinary
possibilities at CMS after discussing
sorry after discussing the femicide
machine by sergio gonzalez rodriguez and
technologies of surveillance and the
border with relation to the novella idea
we also had a more general question
about GREs how highly GREs are weighted
on the application and i'm guessing that
some people out here are also wondering
about that if you want to answer i you
know i said on the admissions committee
many years i well i think we the most
important thing for me at least is the
personal statement and the scores I mean
everybody's scoring high well the scores
are not as important as conveying
through your personal statement who you
are and what you were what what your
values are and how your past
accomplishments lead you to where you
are so I would say personal statement
outweighs scores well I feel that too I
personally feel that too when I'm
reviewing a file but I do know that
sometimes you have a whole you know when
you're reviewing these applications the
the GRE scores do matter to some people
especially the writing scores because
they get concerned if you don't score
high in the writing category that or the
analytical category that it might be a
challenge for doing some of the research
work but
yeah and they you know that I think you
just have to do the best you can on
those those tests people have very mixed
feelings about standardized testing at
this moment in time and so you just have
to try to score the highest you can but
I agree that the writings the personal
statement is really what's important
yeah the core curriculum it really
depends I think there's certain amount
of consistency and that some of the
professors are teaching the same class
year after year but they're also trying
to update the the bibliographies for
those courses I think if you're
interested in that it might be best to
reach out to request some sample syllabi
from the classes because I don't have
them all memorized here but you know it
really just depends on on the class and
who's teaching it but I think it's the
kind of conversation that you should
maybe we can talk to Shannon and myself
and try to send you some syllabi if you
want to see what are things on the
reading list I'm trying to think it's
William Murray Kiyo's teaching the media
theories and methods right now and I
teach the media major media texts again
I just moved here a few years ago but
this was a class that had been developed
to deal with theories of textual 'ti in
relation to various media forms from
films to TV to games and websites and so
you know we did like at least four
articles per week that were related to
various themes in the class and I'd be
happy to share the syllabus with you if
you if you want to send me an email so
you can get a sense of what that looks
like
right now I'm teaching an elective
seminar and it's called
Media Studies machine learning and AI
and it's an attempt to try to look at
how Media Studies and media industries
are shifting in relation to new
recommender systems and search
technologies so we're reading we read a
book called the black box Society we
read a book we've been reading a book a
week because I've decided
to find books in this class so that the
students can understand how to
conceptualize a thesis which is a longer
form than just an essay and so I've been
thinking encouraging them to think about
what does it mean to write a book you
know to read and write a book because a
thesis is like a small book so you need
to understand the structure of a book in
order to be able to conceptualize a
thesis so we read the black box society
we read algorithms of oppression by
Sofia Noble we read behind the screen
which is a new book that just came out
from Sarah Roberts about content
moderators in the social media space
we're reading a book called Netflix
Nations about the globalization of the
Netflix platform and we're reading a
book called Spotify tear down about a
group of researchers that tried to
understand how Spotify works from the
inside and since they face a lot of
blockages from the company they had to
invent their own collaborative research
methods and so the book is kind of about
that process so each week we've been
reading a different book to try to
understand what it means for Media
Studies to be merging with these new
types of computing technologies machine
learning and AI tools we also read a
book called burden of choice by Jonathan
Cohen about recommender systems so sorry
the question was whether you guys can
visit classes
yeah I feel local we don't usually
invite prospective applicants to visit
classes because our cohort is very small
and it would end up you would end up
outnumbering the students in the
classroom but would you invite once
students are admitted
we do invite them when they're making
their decision to attend or not to come
and meet with faculty and sit in on a
class and attempt these estate that was
actually a really good question
what skills do you
well in my lab my one of the goals is I
try to to do collaborative fieldwork as
part of the training in research
training and I also encourage students
to do a lot of writing not just blog
posts but we do co-authored
peer-reviewed journal publications in
the lab so I tend to be more of a
humanities type of orientation but so
III don't have the training to train
students to do a lot of you know
software learning software and doing a
lot of multimedia production but I think
I don't know I think that in the
workshop people tend to learn a lot from
each other as well as from the professor
who invites tech experts to come into
the workshop quite a bit and showcase
various tools and possibilities for use
in their own work my expectations and
hopes are mostly grounded in providing a
space for students to get involved in
scholarly research not just here at MIT
but out beyond this place and to learn
from engaging with people that live in
different circumstances then than they
they have I would I would say that if
you have some basic coding skills that's
always helpful you have more competitive
advantage but if you don't
we have had students come in we had a
documentarian come in who has zero
skills in VR and discovered it while he
was here and really dope right in and
ended up leaving with a lot of the art
skills that he hadn't had previously and
we've had humanists come in and study
coding and programming in fact one of
our faculty Nick Montfort created a
class for them called exploratory
programming in the arts and humanities
and so they ended up with a lot of
programming skills that they hadn't come
in with so it's it's absolutely possible
but it depends a lot on the student how
they want to spend their elective time
their workshop time etc
any any other questions or comments or
yes so the question was about what is
the value of a Media Studies experience
and degree from here at MIT relative to
other maybe compared to other really
high quality I'd was you were okay okay
okay okay yeah yeah no this is so just
to give you a sense I think this is a
really important question from a student
perspective when you're thinking about
which program is going to be a good fit
for you and I think it has to do with
the overall environment of the
university or in this case Institute and
what resources are available for
students I mean here if you get into the
program you pretty much get a research
assistantship that pays for you to go to
school and get the degree that isn't
always going to be the case in all media
studies MA or MS programs sometimes
they're quite competitive and people pay
take out student loans and pay out of
pocket to get that master's degree if
you're admitted here your that is my
serious responding to me you know that
that I think that's a really important
part of it is to think about the
financial aspect this
second part is I think we have a very
unique and eclectic faculty some people
in our department have a background in
sociology
some are documentary filmmakers some are
more humanities based media scholars
some have a background in cognitive
science and interactive media and art so
your and and then yet others have a
background in rhetoric so you have a
broad spectrum of disciplines that are
represented among our faculty in the
comparative Media Studies program if
you're looking for like a really niche
focused program that's very humane
humanities-based this one is a little
different from that and there's also I
think I would say there's a lot more of
an emphasis on applied media education
here not just the reading and the
writing but like the making part it
tends to be quite important in terms of
the classes that are offered and
developed here and the the workshop
module that you end up participating in
I think also just being you know part of
our department is in one building our
departments pretty scattered in terms of
the physical plant of MIT and sometimes
to go back to a question earlier how do
you deal with some of the problems and
challenges I think that's one of the
challenges that we have is that we're a
little bit scattered and so labs might
be in one building and classes might be
over here and meetings kind of but I
think we try to do our best to use the
colloquium to bring people together and
and there's a sense of community that
forms around that event and it brings in
people not just from CMS but from
literature from architecture and even
the department of urban planning and you
know it comes over there called us
parade the department of urban studies
urban studies and planning so
and then the final thing I will say is
that MIT is a powerful brand and that
when you have MIT on your CV or a resume
it can automatically impress some people
now after the scandal that our campus
just went through it might also make
people raise their eyebrows you should
be aware of that then I don't know if
you are aware of the scandal that our
campus has been going through over the
past several months with regard to
accepting financing from a kind of
problematic entity and if anyone wants
to talk about that one on one I'm happy
to discuss that with you but but overall
I think the brand of MIT is a very
powerful one and having moved from a
public university to MIT in the last few
years you just even notice the shift and
the way that people respond you know and
when you say where you work and I I
personally don't always buy those brand
things I you know I I think we have to
have a measured relationship to those
things but I do think that this is a
place that has a history and it it's
known pretty well not only in the United
States but throughout the world and I
think a lot of the people here really
want to do good like they really do want
to do good scholarship and do use
technology to try to facilitate social
change yes
here Jenny and I were just talking about
this the last few days I did some
research on similar programs so this
might be like the ground level so one of
the things I've done over the past
couple years is look at the other school
so when you apply it one thing that you
can or always mention in our other
schools that you're applying to so I was
able to take that information to see you
oh is the most common like where people
that's kind of also a button and then
match that against some rankings that
didn't come out I didn't this year shows
top media studies and communication
programs and look at what the basics of
those other programs probably focused on
and so the difference ended up being
where we stood out was that places like
Yale was a common but also apply to
program and that's filming to be his day
so that was almost purely humanities but
you also have a place like I think
Georgia Tech was one where it's all
building with a little bit of my theory
kind of tacked on the big thing here is
that some of this virtuous cycles
throughout the curriculum is that while
you're taking series of methods you're
also working with a research group on
projects coming out with portfolio
and whether it's or I just put up this
slide because one of the things I had to
do a talk recently about at the 30th
anniversary of a doctoral program and I
had one of the students in my lab pull
some data from the National Center for
Educational statistics to try to look at
the growth of Media Studies over the
last 30 or so years and this is a we're
gonna be putting a blog post up on my
website about this soon so this is a
little fresh but it shows that overall
Media Studies at least coming out of a
social science there's two tracks one
comes out of the social sciences and one
comes out of the humanities and in both
tracks we see pretty steady growth over
the last 30 years so Media Studies is
really a growth area and when we write
this up on my website we're gonna put
all the the numbers of how many programs
there were in 1984 and how many there
were in the last year that we pulled the
data which is 2017 so you get a sense we
also have some charts that break
enrollment in be a master's and PhD
programs down by gender and race and
ethnicity as its collected by the the
national government and so the the
series of slides will include that too
but I just put this up because we do it
is a growth field you know and the big
drop here is explained because basically
the data set was classified as
journalism and mass comm until 1992 and
then they pulled journalism out of the
data set and so it made the stats go
down really low because journalism was
put in its own category and then they
changed the category to mass comm and
then it started to kind of increase and
grow up go up again but we have the
series for the this as well as the film
programs which come out of a kind of a
different institutional track but I
bring this up just to say that this is a
grow
field and there are many programs and
institutions that so that have really
strong media programs it's a fascinating
discipline and it's one where there's a
lot of cutting-edge work going on I
think and a lot of interesting
possibilities for for the futures of
your careers and entering the workforce
whether you go in academia or other
fields too you know startups I don't
think there's a large enough category to
describe
other than acting in that people really
really thrive did you have a question
that you wanted to ask sorry yes yes
actually talking those are the balance
between research and production then you
asked you to what you're interested in
building the good things here but I've
heard a lot of going to research and not
as much about the production so because
you're a little bit more about the types
of things
well I think in my little speech I
talked about my work on civic media I'm
an activist and a professor at the same
time so I'm running this NGO grassroots
NGO doing work with we have a huge
network of NGOs in China it's about like
thousands of them yeah we trained them
to enhance their social media digital
literacy and we have lots of products
coming out of that we recently launched
the project on future village we we
identified villages that have
technological or communication problems
and we do civic hackathons and we create
prototypes so that's some kind of that's
a kind of production driven project and
these are you two you you recently did
workshops yeah so Africa and you're
going to do one in Brazil yeah some of
the students in my lab we've done a
series of workshops called social IT
solutions and the idea is to partner
with universities we partnered with the
the Darussalam Institute of Technology
and the State University of Zanzibar in
Tanzania last January during the I AP
and we went there and ran a two-week
workshop with the we partnered with the
faculty and students there and by the
end of the two weeks the students worked
in teams and they did project prototypes
after having gone out into the field and
done interviews or observations in the
urban space of things that they felt the
internet or mobile phone apps or other
technologies would be useful so it
wasn't just driven by kind
the platform ization of the world where
everybody has to use the same platform
in the same way but what does it mean to
have ground-up grassroots conversations
among people in diverse communities
about the kind of technologies that
they'd like to develop and create and
benefit from financially themselves and
so we had six teams and they had all
this stuff is on our website too but
they they did everything from an
emergency services app they don't have a
900 so if somebody is sexually assaulted
you can't just grab your phone and call
9-1-1 they actually have a very
inefficient emergency services
infrastructure so they had developed a
whole allowed they had gone to a place
and interviewed some police and and
developed a whole system for this that
they presented and they got covered on
the national TV networks and in the
national press and others were doing
projects where they were trying to
develop kind of aggregate the prices of
produce at market places around the city
so that people with limited incomes
could know where they could get the
produce they needed at the right price
given their limited time and moving
around the city and that project was
really amazing
another group focused on lines that they
had to wade in at the hospital the bank
at kind of public service sector places
and they just would wait they'd have to
take off a day of work just to take
their baby to the hospital for a day and
they'd lose all the income that day so
they did a project called Q X so that
they could know when to go there and
that there wasn't a line or they could
get a spot in line so it was really
inspiring to us to get a sense of the
technologically grounded needs that
people felt that they could evolve and
develop themselves in these groups and I
mean that's just a very brief overview
of things that I think are actually
really more nuanced and complex so
but and there are a lot of other people
in the department doing more kind of
applied types of project occasional
games actually yeah I [ __ ] Locke
educational Jane educational games Eric
Klopfer is giving a talk participatory
design we also have a design lab that
works with government industry and
communities to create design thinking
driven products and the game where
students have also created their own
video games one of my favorites was
called a slower speed of light which
allows you to see the world as if you
were traveling and how it might work I I
render my googling and it's kind of fun
and we've had students create virtual
reality games dealing with
socio-economic class and income so yeah
there there are tremendous number of
projects actual hands-on stuff coming
out
do you work as services
yes yeah if you're admitted you are
assigned as a research assistant to a
lab and that is for nine months out of
the year so for two years you have
summers off unless your lab has money
and you want to work you are not
required to work on MIT brakes so at
Christmas break and for spring break
it's have you heard
a student is able to do research at a
place like this for cancer split their
time
so yes if you if you don't mind me
taking this one yes we have had students
who had funding that could be moved
around who ended up working primarily
with with faculty and us and that worked
out really well we did have a student a
few years ago who was hired as a
research assistant by a faculty member
and us and that did not work out so well
and so we're we're cautious about
students doing their research assistant
outside of our program because if you're
working with a faculty that's not in our
department we can't tell them not to do
something so if they're asking their
their research assistant to do entirely
clerical work we can't say hey that's
not the way we run our labs because it's
not allowed so it's it's been done and I
won't say no you can't but I will say
it's the sort of thing that is looked at
cautiously we prefer to keep students
within our own group so that we can
monitor and make sure that it's a
healthy research assistant relationship
anything else don't take this one too
well in the news I read today MIT just
got what was it two hundred and sixty
million dollars from the Lord the seal
of the Lord corporation this was in the
MIT news headline so I mean the kind of
gifts that we that MIT gets they're kind
of astounding the scale but it's a good
question the recession tends to impact
some endowments at private universities
and Institute's it hits public
universities much harder because you
know they are dependent on federal
funding and other often that gets cut in
a recession and even state funding but I
I don't know the answer to that I kind
of doubt it but I don't know for sure if
our funding is somehow reduced we're not
going to accept students and not fund
them and MIT is it doesn't have as much
of an endowment as other private
universities and so we do rely a lot on
the federal government but this
department doesn't rely as heavily on
the federal government as as the
engineering and science schools at MIT
so it's not to say we aren't affected by
a recession but it's not quite as bad No
well thank you all very much for coming
and thanks for your questions and your
interest in the program and please feel
free to let us know if you have
questions one on one will stick around
for a few minutes and I just want to say
thanks for coming today we are all more
than welcome to come to tonight's
program